i don't want to get too excited but
february 2022 looks like it's going to
be absolutely wild for gaming this year
so let's get right into the games coming
out this month
we start with dying light 2 stay human
it's the direct sequel to 2015's zombie
action parkour game dying light and
developer techland has showcased through
numerous trailers that they intend to
expand upon every aspect of what made
the original game such a major success
that means they'll expand on the free
running aspect of the game with even
more ways to traverse the huge city of
the city as well as include new
iterations of zombies for more intense
action the map is four times the size of
the original game and various human
factions and settlements are being
introduced and supposedly have a large
enough impact that it will be worth
giving this game multiple playthroughs
additionally like the original game
dialect 2 will include 4 player co-op
multiplayer everything we've seen so far
looks promising so i'm hoping it's a
knockout on par with if not exceeding
dying light 1. dying light 2 stay human
releases february 4th to pc ps4 ps5 xbox
one xbox series x s and switch
lost ark is a korean award-winning
mmoarpg which was originally released in
2019.
it's finally seeing a western release
this february and many have been waiting
years to be able to play this as
development originally started back in
2011.
that is now 11 years before seeing a
western release to get into a little
more detail lost art is an isometric 2.5
d action rpg in style there are a
multitude of classes you can choose from
including berserker paladin gun lancer
war dancer scrapper summoner and a whole
whole lot more that means you'll get to
choose between aggressive tanks melee
slash ranged combo builds various range
specific builds sorcery and so much more
within that beyond just the combat the
game will also have a focus on story
similar to final fantasy xiv while there
was a closed beta back in november 2021
lost ark finally fully releases to the
west on february 11 2022 specifically
for pc
when thinking about the kings of
fighting games certain franchises always
pop up street fighter tekken guilty gear
soul calibur blazblue smash fatal fury
and of course king of fighters that was
a longer list than i meant to have but i
even left out a bunch of iconic fighting
games series and some of my personal
favorites like rival schools marvel vs
capcom or pocket fighter seriously i
want more pocket fighter
anyways back to king of fighters king of
fighters is one of snk's long-running
flagship fighting game franchises the
first game released in 1994 and it even
had multiple spin-offs but after nearly
six years since the release of king of
fighters 14 king of fighters 15 is
finally on its way
and apparently we're going to see 39
playable characters from the get-go with
this consisting of 13 teams with 3
fighters in each meanwhile the story
will directly follow the events of king
of fighters 14. the king of fighters 15
releases on february 17 to pc ps4 ps5
and xbox series x s
total war has become creative assembly's
flagship series ever since it debuted in
2000 with shogun total war since then
they've covered various historical eras
and finally in 2016 brought to life
warhammer with total war warhammer
however this was only the first part of
a planned trilogy and finally this
february we'll see the conclusion of
that trilogy with total war warhammer 3.
like the former games warhammer 3 will
be a turn-based tactical strategy game
movements around the map happen in a
turn-based fashion with negotiations
being possible however when these fail
battles will take place in real time
what you choose to build will influence
these battles as you can build various
barricades and defensive towers utilize
terrain and attempt to squeeze enemy
armies into strategic kill zones if
you're a fan of strategy games this is
definitely worth keeping your eye out
for total war warhammer 3 releases
february 17 to pc
2017 was an absolutely stacked year in
gaming there was a ridiculous amount of
incredible releases throughout the year
including zelda breath of the wild
persona 5 hollow knight mario odyssey
cuphead and resident evil 7 just to name
a few and while breath of the wild took
many of the year's accolades for
incredible open world gaming the
playstation had its very own absolutely
incredible show-stopping game released
in 2017
and horizon zero dawn horizon created an
open world that slowly opened up to its
main character eloy as you developed new
skills and understanding of how its
incredibly beautiful world worked the
well-crafted story taking place in the
dystopian world where you'll be forced
to hunt down robotic dinosaur-like
creatures
every single aspect of the game was done
well from its stealth to its action
collection and world building its
long-awaited sequel horizon forbidden
west is finally on its way and will
continue aeloy's story with new
mechanics including underwater
exploration whether you played horizon
zero dawn or not horizon forbidden west
will definitely be worth checking out as
horizon has become one of playstation's
must play exclusives horizon forbidden
west releases to the playstation 4 and
playstation 5 on february 18.
when destiny was first released it was
hyped up to incredible degrees similar
to cyberpunk and was met with mixed
reactions manny decided it didn't live
up to the hype and quickly dropped the
game
however destiny 2 did a huge amount to
regain fan and consumer trust and this
free-to-play fps has since attracted an
extremely impassioned and loyal fan base
destiny 2 was first released in 2017 and
has since seen multiple expansions big
and small that have added to both the
story and gameplay content these have
included curse of osiris war mind
forsaken shadow keep and beyond light
fans have eagerly awaited for the latest
expansion the witch queen which was
originally planned for 2021 but pushed
back due to kovid
finally the wait is over and the witch
queen will be releasing with a new
location world activities dungeons a
raid and story elements destiny 2 fans
across all gaming systems can expect to
see the witch queen release on february
22.
codemaster's latest entry into their
racing franchise grid is on its way with
grid legends this time around inspired
by the netflix series formula 1 drive to
survive codemasters will be including a
strong focus on a story mode the game
will include various racing modes and
over 130 tracks covering multiple cities
around the world and more than 100
vehicles from drift cars to semi-trailer
trucks while the game does include
realistic driving handling to an extent
it's not a driving simulator game and
has arcadey elements to it including a
focus on drifting which if i'm being
completely honest is exactly my kind of
racer i love when it's sort of realistic
but still has that fun arcadey feel
for me you have to have at least a bit
of arcadiness so i'm excited to see that
something brand new to this series will
be the ability for players to create
their own races in the race creator this
means you'll be able to customize the
routes obstacles rules and restrictions
want tons of ramps and boosts in a
rain-soaked race with all different cars
racing each other
you got it want something fair and even
you can create that too the races you
create can be played both offline and
online with friends and strangers alike
grit legends releases the pc ps4 ps5
xbox one and xbox series x slash s on
february 25th
here it is
i've been saving this one for last
also i've been going in chronological
order so
you know after a short delay from
software's latest ip eldon ring is
finally releasing this upcoming month
while it's never a good idea to get too
hyped for a game before release from
software is one of the few companies i
have complete trust in to deliver an
incredible experience and they haven't
let me down yet from demon souls to dark
souls to bloodborne and seikiro every ip
has been a well-crafted vision and
masterpiece with eldon ring from is
taking their tried and true weighted
third-person medieval combat from dark
souls but introducing a vast open world
to the mix what that brings is a whole
new means of exploration and brand new
possibilities with how to tackle the
game while i don't want to spoil too
much for anyone who's trying to steer
clear before release i can say that i
was lucky enough to get my hands on the
network test in late 2021 and the game
is absolutely shaping up to be exactly
what you'd imagine an open world from
soft game to be it includes smaller
dungeons within the world that aren't
too time intensive but still include
some interesting mechanics and bosses
while also including full-scale legacy
dungeons in line with the types of areas
we've seen in previous fromsoft games
the brand new ability to ride and fight
horseback brings a whole new element to
traversal in combat and i absolutely
cannot wait for the full release alden
ring is set to release to pc ps4 ps5
xbox one and xbox series x s on february
25th
okay this one isn't a game but it's
still worth mentioning after being
delayed for two months valve's major
console and pc competitor the steam deck
is currently set to release sometime
this february the steam deck is valve's
attempt at creating a mobile gaming
machine with it having a similar design
and build to the nintendo switch the
idea being that players would now have
an extremely portable and comfortable
way to play their steam library anywhere
granted i'd have to imagine laptops
would be one of their competitors while
the initial reaction to the steam deck
was extremely positive we'll have to
wait and see how many people latch onto
it and how widely used it actually
becomes
so there you have the biggest games
coming out this february was there
anything you thought i should have
included and what do you think of the
steam deck more importantly
i can't wait to see all you lowly
tarnish in eldon ring
let's
go
you